那么接下来的话就由联书给大家带来入门音视频然后从写个播放器开始的技术分享对然后接下来的话把时间交给联书你可能要先退一下我才能你看得见吗Hello可以看得见联书你正面开一下视频吗可以看一下开视频怎么看对PPE是可以看得见的
然后声音也都可以看见了吗可以可以没问题好那我就开始好接下来的时间交给联书嗯大家好我是联书来自u c然后以前做过一些swift和函数式编程以及端致等方面的技术真相然后今年的t刷龙在去年的那个
也是老司机替哨龙组织举办的那个WWDC playground里面给大家分享过一个入门端只能从写一个轻量级的神机网络开始那今天我就继续秉承咱这个入门系列给大家介绍一下啊但如果你想入门音视频的话那我们可以尝试写个简单的播放器开始
然后自我介绍一下就是我目前是在UC认知然后是在那个短视频客户端的负责人然后我个人的一些研究兴趣主要就是跟我以前的分享是正相关的就主要是函数字编程然后音视频和端正的方面的一些事情首先第一个部分我介绍一下我们为什么要学习音视频技术他比主要有两个点第一个是当这种的看法
音视频技术它有一个非常广泛的应用场景就我们现在在多快崛起来之前其实直播就已经比较热门了就是人们在消费内容通过手机和电脑消费内容的兴趣逐步的随着带夸和设备的性能的擅长从图文迁移到了视频所以大家会发现我们最近很多消遣的时间其实都在看视频
他的应用场景就包括了视频的播放然后视频的拍摄以及直播推流还有就是一些每年相关的技术所以其实现在基本上每一个互联网公司不管他做产品是什么类型的他总有涉及到内容的业务那既然如此他内容最终视频也会是内容这块业务的一个核心所以应用视频技术他其实是有非常广泛的应用场景的
那第二点就是他有一个非常稳健的技术基本盘这什么意思呢就是说白了就是他的技术其实都比较老就是我们移动开发的同学大家都对于技术的根碟有非常刻骨铭心的认识我们学一个框架或者说学一套SDK很有可能过一两年他就不变了但是你英视频技术整天用的这些东西无论是视频的边界码标准sd164
然后这个其实十几年前甚至二十年前就开始用了然后到现在他其实也没怎么变已经说你二十年十年前你花一个月时间学了一种东西然后你现在从事相关动作你发现还用得上对所以说他其实性价比确很高的而且他不管怎么变他的很多核心的思路也没有变就比如说像
图下血氧的技术以前我们都是OpenGL,OpenGL也用了二三十年了,但是虽然现在苹果在推Metal但是它的很多原理和很多做交实践的方法论本质上跟你学OpenGL的时候学到的东西都是一样的所以音视频技术可以说是一个RR很高的它看起来有一定的入乳门卡,但学起来是一个RR很高的技术
那接下来这一批我们就举几个例子来先让大家感兴的认识一下就是我们常聊的音视频技术包含了一些最核心的基本概念我以一个短视频的生产和消费为例子首先我们先聊生产什么叫短视频的生产就是比如说你用等音来拍一个视频然后把它发布然后这个就是所谓的生产
那我们先看第一条链额拍摄那首先从摄像头它会涂出来一些图像的数据就是摄像头捕捉到你比如你的脸你的自拍的时候然后这些数据是用YV的格式来捕捉的那一般来说会通过一个GPU的shader然后把它转换成一个RGB的格式然后RGB的格式又会上传到GPU里面生成一个OpenGL的文理
然后这个文理呢,也会到一个负责处理美颜,瘦脸下的一个模块然后对于文理中你的脸进行一些处理然后之后就会分流,分流一个流拿去手机上选出来,因为我们在自拍的时候,我们要看一下我们自拍的什么样子嘛就是上屏,那第二个流呢,会重新把处理过的数据,独成RGB数据并转到这个YUV格式然后再给到
视频的编码器,也就是HDR News的Encoder去做编码这是视频这条链路那音频这条链路呢就是那个麦克风会捕捉到你说的音频的数据然后会通过PCM这样一种原始数据的格式然后给到我们的音频编码模块然后音频编码最终也会把原始的音频数据进行编码之后和编码后的视频数据一起交给一个叫Muxer
这样的一个封关器然后这个封关器最终交替的安排编码后的视频和编码后编码后的音频为什么要交替呢就是你首先你肯定不希望你的文件前面是视频后面是音频那你要同时播的话你就需要那个文件的指纸在其中疯狂思考这肯定是不符合一期的那所以我们就需要把视音频按照时间错的逻辑交替的写到最终的
容器里面,这个容器就是我们常见的MP4就是其中一种容器那MP4我们会上传到云端,然后效发到看抖音的那个客户端然后到客户端呢,它就会通过一个叫D-MOX你看刚刚我们提到了MOX和现在我们产D-MOX就是解封装器解封装器会把音频和视频的数据分别拿出来然后再给到那个音频解码器和视频解码器然后
视频解码器同样解出来是YUV的数据,我们又需要将它转换到RGB然后再上屏然后最终我们就视频给音频同时播放然后下面这一泡其实就是一个不放弃的处形它不放弃本质做的事情其实就是这样那为什么我们每一次要转换上屏都需要转换RGB呢就是因为YUV它并不是一个被大多数,绝大多数显卡支持的格式
在我们在渲染的时候常规还是使用RGB这种格式这一批反正我们就给大家介绍一下那个视频从拍摄到播放到盖的一个流程然后它里面就会有非常多的基础概念到底有哪些概念呢我们在这里面再分开列一下首先我们有封装格式就是我们比如说MP4、MP3和FLB
就我们常见导家的这种视频后罪名一般来说是封装格式封装格式呢它定义了说你编码后的音频和视频通过怎么样的一种协议或者格式存储成最终的一个视频文件那第二个呢就是视频的编解码标准比如说VP8、VP9和现在常用的HD264和HD265它定义的是什么呢是你一个原始的图像数据
假设比如说100成100的图像每个图像有四个像素点四个纸来表示二级BA然后我怎么把它编码成一个要缩后的格式那这个是视频编解码的标准那音频也有自己的编解码标准然后非常多但基本上我们常论的就是AAC然后刚才提到那个麦克风录制到的声音其实就是可以理解为音频的原始数据一般叫PCM
那说回视频,视频的原始数据就我刚刚提到的就是比如说位图是RGB组成的但也有Yov的格式那RGB和Yov的区别是什么呢就是RGB是通过红绿蓝三个颜色的分量的权重来确定一个颜色而Yov则是通过一个Y的挥助图和UV两个维度的亮度来确定一个颜色
那不同的颜色空间根据海列方式又会有不同的具体格式就比如RGB在大家如果和那个CB派对速报复打交道的时候应该也会见过就是有他又分为RGB RGB A BG2 BG2A本质上就是他在内存中排列顺序不同那同例YUV也会分为非常多细分的格式比如说4R2 4R0
这些但这里就不做展开的介绍,大家只需要知道我们这些都是我们在处理比如说播放器的时候经常需要导交的东西而音视频的工程无论是做什么业务最终其实很多代码都是在处理各种各样格式的转换要索或解要索,或者从这个颜色空间转换成那个颜色空间以及各种call in case的处理好,接下来我们就来进入今天的正题
我们今天做的事情有三件事情首先我们要到一个跨平台的工程校子第二个我们要实现一个最小的播放器我们就起一个叫Tiny Player的名字第三件事就是我们要在IOS上把我们这个播放器跑起来但我们实现播放器本质单是跨平台的理论上来说在安卓上通过NDK以及书写少量的敲接代码也可以移植到安卓
对只是我现在电脑没有安卓的环境所以我就以iOS作为例子首先是搭这个轿子搭这个轿子我们当然我们聊一个跨平台工程我们需要注意的东西是哪些呢首先是平台代码的分率小间因为你绝大多数几乎所有跨平台的工程都会涉及到一个点就是你如何隔离平台的代码
那我们首先最简单的方式就是用红比如说你一个CPP文件你iOS的地方你就用一个红判断如果是iOS就这行如果是安卓就内行但是这种口温无形是很差的那我们就可以使用继承更多态比如说我们可以搞一个CIA叫做抽象类然后在安卓iOS上分别使用它的籽类
这样子的话,然后你在你跨平台代码就会通过持有这个抽象类的指针来做很多各种各样的操作和传递,而不会被平台代码所污染。第二个点就构建的机制,构建的机制分两层,一个是你的CIA加工程,你要怎么去编译呢?就尤其是包含平台代码的CIA加工程。
比如说你iOS你可能包含了很多.m.m.m文件以及你的cpp文件那安卓更多则是包含了他自己的交往文件那现在比较常用的构建体系最常用的肯定是Cmake但也有一个最近看流行起来的Basel也不是最近嘛就是国内好像B站用的比较多国外的话谷歌用的比较多但是他的资料和应用性我个人感觉应该是还得比Cmake差一些
但如果说你没身边的人都在用的话应该就会好很多那勾兼机的第二个点就是你要使用一个那个交叉编辑的工具链交叉编辑是什么意思呢就是所谓编辑系它最终就是要把原码编辑成当前这个机器能跑个那个二斤制字节码但是IS情况一动开发不一样
我们是需要在mic上编译能够在另外一个操作系统iOS上跑的代码所以我们就需要iOS的工具链来在mic上做这个编译但这种东西其实目前都是现成的本质上就是在使用超扣的只是说可以在低的号码上找这种交叉编译的工具链的文件然后接受到CMEC里面能够节省很多配置的工作那第三个点就是开发效率就是你
写跨平台工程你要怎么样翻遍的使用超购进行调试呢然后这些我们在接下来都会设计的那第一件事我们就签设计向我们的目录结构首先我们有一个粒子目录然后它放的是相应的基础库第二是它有一个Source目录然后Source目录就分为两块两块一个是跨平台的部分core一部分是平台相关的部分platform然后iOS就在里面建议你讲
然后另外我们还有一个弹幕工程的目录就比如examples然后分别放上双端的工程最后我们写一个build的目录作为中间厂路的目录那接下来我们就要考虑如何保我们这个工程给编起来那首先就是Cmake List它这个东西看起来是比较麻烦的但是你仔细看了一下你会发现它除了余法比较少之外还是比较清晰的我这里就挑几个点讲一下我在代码中
标注的1234分别对应你看一我们先声明了一个叫tiny player的toget然后进行了一些设置然后二我们把core里面的所有代码命名为sourcefile这样一个名字然后把那个platform里面的所有代码命名为platformfiles这样一个名字这样一说这两个名字就代表了我们所有的原代码然后第三部分就是设置header search pass
和设置library search pass这个就类似巧克力的设置然后4的话就是可以设置一些巧克力的team id啊还有就是设置一些code sign的东西啊用这一条式的然后另外就是因为我们在有的地方需要实动release所以我们先设置不使用那个lc然后后面的5的话就是我们会需要把
在CMAKE里面关联到我们iOS平台层的一些firmwork那这个怎么关联呢就是可以通过一个解决生命的一个红函数可以很方便的去超扣的目录里面把这些iOS firmwork的路径关联到这个toddata然后这个呢我没有写带码因为这个直接超作业就行了就不在这里展开然后6的话呢解决通过我们定义的那个iOS firmwork这种函数来报iOS的依赖都交进去
然后7的话呢就等于说我们除了依赖一些互联络和之外我们还依赖比如fmpack一些金带库所以我们在其通过talkit linked libraries的函数来保我们依赖的其他的金带库关联到我们的talkit就这样我们就完成了我们这个工程的那个cmake的配置然后我们再通过一个cmake干击然后指定一个首先在这里面
一个是我们通过翻译超扣的这个参数来决定说我们并不需要编译它而是我们申请一个超扣的工程然后我们再设置脱庆的文件脱庆就是刚才提到的交超编译的文件这个点画板上也是很多大家直接操作也行并且再指定我们是要编译一个拳击
和相对应的那个C最后一个source就是我指定了那个Cmake list的目录相当于告诉Cmake指定你要按照刚才我们写的Cmake list或者说你要去我们指定一个目录找Cmake list来生成我们的工程然后大家可以看到生成的工程就如照图所示然后它默认的那个汇报那个原文件和图文件分成两个目录来放然后这个时候我们再创建一个
另外一个demo工程叫tinyplayerdemo然后把刚才的工程直接拖到这里面来然后你就会发现我们刚才创建的超过工程就可以作为一个target依赖的动态库的target被添加到我们demo工程的依赖中就是红框宽柱的那个leavetinyplayer.leave然后这个时候其实我们就可以假设我们在tinyplayer已经添加了一些代码那我们就可以在这个demo工程中
使用这些代码来做一些事情这个就是一个代码工程的教导,当然你甚至你可以衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬衬
首先我们先设计一下聊一下不关键的照购不关键的照购其实就是刚才那张图我们会发现它的本质就是首先有一个解封安器DEMOX从那个封装比如MP4文件里面给分流读出视频和音频的数据然后分别给到视频和音频的decoderdecoder出来的数据很多时候都需要进行一些转换就比如说yoe数据需要转向2GB
才能给到渲染器,把他渲染到屏幕上那音频数据同样也需要转换就比如说iOS的音频设备反问iOS的音频输出设备也就是那个speaker老吧是需要通过iOS的audio unit但你不同的设备你看说他接收的产量率这些音频
PCM的格式是不一样的所以我们就需要通过音频转换来根据你的设备的能够接受的candles和产量硕来把这个视频中本身编网的那个PCM的格式转换为你能接受的PCM格式这个叫Audio Convert的作用然后给掉Audio Render其实就是调用平台的一些音频硬件的访问的API然后把它声音给播出来
然后你也知道大家也看到了就是它是两条独立的路线但是它最终都需要做一个音视频的同步来避免有一方过快然后导致我们看视频觉得音画不同步这样的问题那并且每一个组件之间我们都会停脚一些fifal的q来做一些仿存因为避免某段时间它很烤的时候会特别影响体验如果有q的话就可以解决改善这样的问题
那换成我们今天要实现的核心组件首先我们要实现一个Decoder大家可以看到Decoder我画了一个虚现的框就代表说我们今天会把converter和Decoder以及demox的这些几个部分都实现为一个大的组件需要Decoder因为我们的部分器比较小嘛就没必要拆人这么多内那第二个组件呢就AudioRender,AudioRender顾名思义就是保
我们 decode 图出来转换好的音频数据负责汇制汇制给老爸vido render 就同样是把转换出来的视频数据汇制给屏幕那最终这三个组件就构成了我们的 tiny player那接下来说到那个音视频开发我们都会选一个基础的机构账因为它里面涉及到太多的东西都不现实就是你自己从零开发那是常见的
开了旧站有两个,一个是FMPag一个是外宝ATC他们有一些相同点就是取决应用什么视角去看比如说相同点就是他们都是开源的并且他们里面都具备一些基础应设定的处理能力第二个是他们都能做直播就比如说MPag他可以直接通过他的那个缩写的封装然后做那个RTMP的推流
外网RTC直接可以通过RTC协议的旁路推流来做直播但是他们俩其实是完全不一样的东西并且测重点设计也不一样M-PAC它本质瞄准的是一个音视频处理的基础库它的重点是它实现了一个多格式的兼容性就是它可以解码非常多的东西并且可以编码很多的东西然后它可以做很多转码比如说把你的MKV的封装格式转成MP4
或者说把你的vp9的编码的视频转成2264编码的视频而YBOTC的话它更加测证的是一个实时的音视频通信引擎它的重点不是对音视频隔世的支持而是它内部实现了非常多的音频处理算法以及落网对抗算法它的目的就是保证在实时通信的场景里面能够尽可能的流畅而且它作为一个引擎而iPhonePad是一个基础库YBOTC部分功能也是依赖于iPhonePad的
OK,对,说了我一句话,就是我们做播放器,首选就是FMPEGFMPEG官网是这么介绍套的,就是我翻译一下,就是一个非常厉害的,跨平台的解决方案,能够录制转换和推留音频和视频数据简单来说就是并且它能够解码编码转码,解封码叫略竞等等等等总之一些东西都能播,都能够处理
只要是人类和机器创造的东西反正就很厉害,那他们主要组成有这些,首先它包含三个迷你行工具FFProbe是可以修讨一个视频链接或者视频文件来得到一些它的编辑网相关信息用来分析问题FFPlay是它实现的一个非常精简的迷你行的播放器
FMPEG是它的一个命令函工具用来做一些转帽或者说因视频处理的工具而这三个工具其实它都是依赖于右边这些开发库就是分为AVutile,AVcodec,AVformat和AVdevice还有FilterScale然后关键点其实就是codec跟format你可以理解为codec就实现了编辑帽而format就实现了解封装
device是实现了一些设备相关的能力而filter实现的是它的一些基于cpu和gpu的一些图像处理和音频处理的能力下面的那个sw scale是做视频格式转换就是图像的格式比如从那个RGB转移YVN类似这样子或者到小的转换那下面的这个最下面的sw sample是做音频格式转换就是它可以把你任意类型格式的
音频原始数据转成你想要的PCM数据那可以转成一些的就比如说是你的存储的位宽还有采样率还有频道这些都可以转换那我们这次的decoder组件就会依赖av format和av codec而我们的audio converter组件就会依赖于sw resample这个组件
首先第一部分我们要设计一下PlayerPlayer我们就从字柄相向设计吧就我们先看我们想要的Player是一个什么样的样子我们就先把这个类写出来首先它就是一个Player的类那它可以通过set a video URL设置一个视频的播放地址
然后他就可以提供play,pause,stop,open,这样几个方法并且他可以给回一个平台的view就比如给回的view,iOS平台,UiView那我可以把这个播放器的view添交到我的app下面那他的private变量我就不说了然后说一下这些private的方法吧,就比如说我需要出实话并且我需要那个两个 thread一个用来做那个渲染
做那个从那个安皮子文件里面解封端和解某这样一个所谓的锐的slide loop我还需要另外一个现成是把视频渲染到屏幕上那为什么dark等会会到为什么音频渲染不学一个现成的就跟我待会会讲然后我们先看一下右边用访案例用访案例在iOS里面就是我们通过那个cli2的贷网扭出一个tiny player出来
然后再通过调用它的git,played player view的方法,挠到它的这个不忘记的view并且设置这个view的frame,然后添加到我们的app上面然后我们再通过bando读出一个mp4,然后调用它的site URL方法设置给它,之后依次调用open和play,那么这个播放器应该就能播放了
本质上来说,这一个这一页就是我们今天要做的事情的一个需求文码,就我们需要实现这样的一个类那我们先看一下那个Player的现场模型刚才提到我们首先有Rede ThreadRede Thread主要去就是Decoder运行的职责它会尝试从MP4里面不断的解封装出新的视频和音频数据,并且会对它们做解码解码后的视频和音频以真的形式存到两个
Q里面视频的存到video frames音频的存到audio frames然后另外一个现成是video render thread然后它主要是跑video render这个组件它会不断的去找video frames然后最新的frame然后把它选择出来音频的就不太一样像因为iOS的那个音频是靠audio unit去跟系统硬件的交道的它的工作方式是你
创建并且启动AudioUnit它会按照它输出的频率和节奏不断的来找你要最新的数据然后你就负责它来找你要的时候你把最新的音频针给填进去换句话来说音频其实也是有一个Strike只不过这个Strike是AudioUnit内部托管的然后它每次需要数据的时候它会调用一个AudioRender Coreback然后你在coreback里面把最新的数据填给它它就可以把你把这个音频给选出来也是播放出来
OK,那这个大得键组件讲完了,那我们接下来就讲一步步怎么实现的,首先Decode的组件那首先我们要实现Decode的组件,我们需要设计一些数据结构比方说我们先设计一个通用的Decode的frame这样一个类,那它包含了这个frame的type比如说视频和音频包含了这个frame解码后的数据的原始之真然后包含了这个frame的长度以及它
所代表的音频和视频数据的Duration和Position那第二步呢我们就在基于这个类来声明一个解码后的视频帧的这样一个结构因为我们解码后的视频是YUV的数据嘛味道方面会去处理我们把它视频帧增加比如Wise和Heat以及YUV三个指针这样的一个字类并且我们会把
为了书写翻变 我们把那个 decoded frame用sharp point的方式来存储然后生命一个快决的列表方法framewack可以 大家只要记住framewack它是一个堆裂就行了 是一个存储的 decoded frame共产之间的堆裂那 decoded 我们现在开始来设计这个类它有几个核心的函数
一个是open就导开文件那具体做的事情呢就是初始化fmpack的context来做一些必要的数双操作这个就不展开了因为是基本比较模板这些写法到时候直接参考github的那个工程即可第二个类就是get a new frame就是播放机会调用来找他拿最新的解码后的针和对应的类型以及
在private里面两个内部方法叫一个是get a video phone from package一个get audio phone from package那顾名思义他其实就是我这里说要package的这个概念大家可以理解成fm pack解封罩完成之后他会保当时还是解封完完成之后的数据还是编码后的视频和音频吧他会把他封装在一个叫package的结构上面换句话来说给一个package的给到
后续的流程,那我们的解码其实就是要从这个package里面把这个具体的音频跟视频的数据给解出来所以我们这两个私有方法就是负责把解封装出来的package读出对应的视频和音频OK,那我们先来第一步就是解封装怎么解呢,它其实首先它得有一个循环,我要循环就不断的解,直到解到EALF
我这没写,因为我带帮太长了,我伤掉了换句话来说就是我什么时候要退出这个循环呢,就是我在每个循环都会尝试去绿的一个新的frame出来那这个frame就是存储在这个package里面当然我的反问,当时我需要做很在第一步跟第二步之间我需要针对这个rat做很多的判断有可能是出错了,有可能是没有解决东西但你要尝试继续解啊有可能是到文件摸过来什么的
当我到文件墨我再退出去OK那当当次呢就是我们会使用AVV的Frame来从解封装器读取下一个Packet然后呢我们会通过Packet到对应的是RubyNex判断到视频和音频然后分别调用我们两个私有方法Get a videoFrame还是和Get a audioFrame从里面解除一帧或者几帧视频帧或音频帧
那当然它的iPad的规矩规定是一个package只会有一种类型的数据所以说像于说我们不管最终解出来是几整这几整一定跟package类型是一样的然后我们最终会根据这个类型把这个这个frame那个设置添交到那个result这个对列里面这个对列因为传的是一个引用所以说我们是可以影响到它外面的值得像于说我们最终就是把
不断的在循环解出最新的Packet从Packet中再调用这两个sale方法解出视频和音频帧然后把这些帧都插入到传餐进来的result类里面对列里面那接下来就来到重点重点就是刚才提到的get a video frame就实际解冒的方法那它要怎么做呢首先
我们要先把这个Packet发送给FM Packet解码器怎么发是通过AVCodecSendPacket这样一个方法把Packet就是刚才解出来的发给解码器那它怎么转是哪个解码器呢大家可以看到第一个参数是V6CodecCodec这个东西在初识化的时候会创建给你解码器完毕接下来发格之后还没完我们学一个循环循环是我们要不断的找解码器要
我们节码完成的frame那就通过av codec receiveframe来要因为刚才也提到一个package的可能是有多个证的所以说我们需要一直要要到这个package的真的已经没有东西了那我们这个要到的内容呢就存储在这个vframe里面vframe是一个avframe是fmpack的frame结构就不是我们那个decode的frame我们现在要做的就是把这个vframe里面的内容转换成我们的decode的vframe的内容
那首先就是提取到从CodexCodex提取到它的wise hat然后设置给我们的那个videoframe的结构就 decode的videoframe然后类型设置为videon因为这回是处理videon包含以及基于它的fmhack的结构体计算它的duration and position最后再通过一个方法从av frame的数据存储方式里面
分别读取说yuv的数据然后给到那个我们的 decoded video frame的这三个数据之间这个方法这里就不展开了,它只是一些数据转换的工作并且最终我们把这个frame铺实到那个我们的那个结果的那个vector那接下来就是那个音频数据的节码就是首先那边视频
叫子是一样的,先send package,然后再receive frame然后或者接完后的音频证接下来有个重点就是我们需要使用swr convert就是刚才提到sw resample那个组件的一个方法来加音频数据进行重产样那这个重产样的原因就是因为不同设备的它的那个产量率跟数据格式有不同的要求那最终我们就把重产样的数据创建成为
Decody的因为我们Decody的frame已经本善就已经有一个原始数据的指证了所以音频frame我们并不需要创建子类我们直接用一个积累的指证就可以来转那个容纳音频的那个数据并且最终我们指定他的type为音频frame即可可以看到这边核心的就是首先我们创建了一个和那个
convert之后的buff and size一样到的那个buff给这个我们的那个tcode的frame都是这样然后我们再把这个data这个data就是刚才考备进去的那个data然后copy到这个我们frame的buff里面ok 那接下来就创建就解冒和解封状的部分已经基本讲完了接下来我们就讲一下那个视频渲染的模块那视频渲染的模块这样是渲染它又涉及到跟viewer搞交道 那我们要怎么样格决那个
平台贷网和跨平台的贷网呢首先我们就设置了PlayerView这样一个跨平台的类的结构它有一些长过的方法比如说Prepare Layers比如说板定那个平台View的RenderBuffer以及Present就是渲染还有Setup就舒适化这样的一些方法然后我们再新建一个新建一个LC的类叫TinyPlayer应该是TinyPlayerView这边写错了
然后我们首先在这个我们新建文件里面然后创建一个那个这个playerview的籽类叫playerviewplantful然后我们就在那个mm文件里面实现那个再证明一个tinyplayerview的oc类然后接下来我们就只需要说在这个mm文件里面实现通过那个override的那个cjj的playerview的
那些方法然后在这些方法里面然后去操作我们创建的那个OC的view即可因为我们在一个关键的点就是我们通过Platform Insta Holder这样子我们可以让这个CLL类CLL类持有那个一个控制阵那么我们就可以把这个OC类关联到这个CLL类里面这样子的话其他的播放器其他的地方只需要跟Playview Platform打交道
然后这个类可以是iOS跟安卓分别实现的然后最终调用的时候就可以通过这个类的具体方法比如present然后我们在实现里面因为这个已经是oc的实现了嘛那我们就可以通过它存储的控制阵营然后转化为我们那个oc的view然后最终调用ocview来实现那个对于平台带毛的那个隔离渲染器首先它的第一个环节是要准备渲染
就prepare render那首先它第一步就是我们要设置那个平台层的CAEA计调layer的这样一个属性就是prepare那个iOS当你一个view你想给计调用一个view的layer想给计调用你需要把他的layer赶这个那第二步那就需要第二步其实就是亏了buffer这个方法他又做了几件事情首先他需要创建一个RenderBuffer
并且把RenderBotter板定到PlayerView上面当品理解为RenderBotter是OpenGL选了一个终点这个终点要跟一个View板定最终这些内容团体在View上汇制出来那第二个方法是创建FVO就是FrameBotter并和RenderBotter板定RenderBotter板定了View但是你又不能直接保东西不发面直接保东西直接汇制到RenderBotter上面我们一般是会创建一些FrameBotter然后保FrameBotter和RenderBotter板定
然后再汇制到frame爆发上面即可那第三步就是创建G1Program并且在这个Program里面我们要加上yuv2rgb的shader然后最后就是初始化顶减和违离坐标就是第四对然后具体这些实现我是实现为一些 utility 方法大家可以感兴趣参考代码那最后就是Renderframe这样一个步骤
那Render Frame这样一个步骤,首先第一步就是清空挥制的善用文熟悉技要的同学到应该都不陌生这样的协访第二步就是我们会保frame的yuv数据,就刚才我们从decode那边提取的,擅闯并且板定成一个文理其实最终是板定三个文理,我们会保yu和v三个buff,板定三个文理那第三步就是我们会通过文将文理通过和program板定的shader,也就是yuv突发GB的shader把它汇制到framebuff上面
然后并且然后一位FriendBuffer已经自动版面RenderBufferRenderBuffer版面View接下来我们就要调用Present就是通知平台层我们可以把东西上屏了那么自然内容就已经汇制出来接下来是那个AudioRender的介绍AudioRender它其实内容也比较多尤其是AudioUnit的使用这块今天不会特别展开但我们就强调一个在AudioUnit的初始框里面
有几个关键的点就是你一定要冰具音频解冒后的格式就是你那个 SW Convert 函数的转出来的格式来设置你 Audio Unity 的输入格式因为我们之前设置那个 SW R 的输入格式输出格式是 AV Sample Format S16那所以这一点我们就和 Audio Unity 的定不太匹配它默认的是 32 位的输入所以我们就需要通过 Audio Unity 的 Side Property
来设置到使用format,然后定义到的那个byte-per-sample是那个seinter16这样的格式,不然的话就出现一个问题对,初识化就是要注意这一点那第二点,初识化完成之后就是那个Render Coreback刚才提到那个AudioUnit的方式是,但它需要数据的时候会调一个coreback来找你脑数据然后脑数据的话,它会闯入一个iodator里面有一般有两个buffer,然后分别对应的是那个
左右声道的数据然后这个时候我们需要几步第一步我们会把入餐的buffer都清空第二步就是我们要调用那个player的那个render方法把数据填到那个renderbuffer的那个这个buffer中然后最后一步第三步就是把我们从player拿到的audio的数据分别填到那个iodata中然后两个声道填的一样就可以了
那我刚才提到我们最终的核心填数据的方法是在player中实现的那我们player中怎么实现的呢就是首先我们会把入餐的报告给支空然后这个也是必须的步骤第二个就是我们要在这一步我们要获取audio frames就存储的是那个对列我们要从头部获取马上要处理的音频帧然后音频帧的话然后痛我们会根据入餐frames跟channel的计算我们这一次要
扩皮的数据 关键话来说就是audio unit每次回掉你我需要多少数据的时候他是不会不一定会消费完整的一帧数据的比如说一帧200字节比如这一次audio unit你只给我80字节就好了那么你就需要把这个offsite就80的offsite和单切你现在处理的人存下来然后再笑一次audio unit再找你要数据的时候你要优先把这120之前剩了120字节先给他
然后才能处理效率战,不然就会丢数据下面这些本身都是在处理这个逻辑就记录offside然后下一次比如下一次current audio frame它就不是near了,那么我们就可以继续把它根据offside,把它上一次没有传绑的数据传完对,就是这一趴的一个重点那ok,我们把所有组件都讲完了,那接下来我们把这个跑起来试一下,就是把我们的decoder player还有就是
都实现了之后包括发现视频其实很早就完了然后音频反而播了半天这个其实就是因为在一些设备上视频渲染视频音频要快的因为音频你有多少数据比如说你5秒的数据
那么你不管怎么样你都是要5秒钟才能把这些数据一个一个的播完因为音频数据天生就是跟时间是有关系的但视频不一样就比如你同样是30张图片30张的视频假设有30个视频帧那你在30fps的那个视频里面你可以播一秒那你在60fps你只能播半秒
而我们现在都还没有设置FPS,所以相应说他就直接会导到机器的极限,把你全部视频就马上卸了嘛所以他就会比音频快很多那接下来就引入一个问题,就播放器里面最重要的一个模块音视频同步他还没有三种方式,第一种是以视频的为转就比如音频去追视频但是这种情况不是说视频可以一直疯狂往前播,是视频本身他也会有一个FPS的限制
那第二种就以音频为准,就我们假设音频一定准的视频去追或者等音频第三种就以系统时钟为准那我们一般怎么选呢,最终行业都会选择以音频为准因为比如视频真一考一下或者说播的快一些人也是没有那么敏感的但音频考一下,整个体感就会非常明显那所以我们这里也是以音频为准而我们实际的音视频同步目前也非常的简单就是我们只需要在视频渲染之前
我们首先计算一下单前这个视频和单前音频的offside的差距如果说到底200,那就说明视频播得太快了那我们就这一针还是保留,然后我们sleep一下那如果小于-200,那就说明说音频播得很快了,那我得注意一下音频那就把这,我就补血量这一针,但是也把这一针给删掉,现在又跳针那如果说差不多呢,在这个某个范围以内呢,那我们就正常的删掉这一针,并且血量这一针
那我们再看一下有了音频可以看到音频的视频几乎是同时结束的接下来就是我今天的分享大概就已经全部走完了我们按照顺序实现了一个非常简单的视频播放功能但主要目的不是说实现这个播放器而是说给大家那个还是演示一下说
音视频基础一些基本的处理方式和一些处理的重点吧好谢谢大家好的这边非常感谢联书的这个分享啊就是刚才联书通过自己这个时期大概四五十分钟的分享给大家就是总结了怎么样就是做一个非常完备的一个视频播放器然后内容非常精彩就不仅涉及了啊音视频的解码甚至包括了就是一些
软件编译相关的一些东西对然后的话非常感谢联书然后辛苦了我们中间稍事休息然后我们这边开始今天的第二轮抽奖然后抽奖结束之后会进入EVE访谈的环节然后我这边来给大家共享一下我的屏幕